dont les assiettes temps approfondissent
au genou j'ai pas toujours pourquoi tu
as pris tout ça alors
parce que c'est gratos le all inclusive
c'est de voir la maman cousin conseils
de vieil pro remis au buffet premiers
transats pour les boissons ont mais non
mais moi de zombies kokoro brin inquiet
râle quand deux tiers d'eau ok alors cap
brown olindo ville
il faut mettre le paquet sur les
animations je ne veux pas voir un mot
qui s'ennuient un mot qui s'éclate c'est
un mot qui va bien est un mot qui va
bien c'est un bon mot qui ne se seraient
pas déjà croisé quelque part tous les
codes peut-être non
[Musique]
je le dis comme ça en passant je suis
retraité et veuf mon livre très libre
c'est bon à savoir traverser
j'ai perdu mon baluchon c'est la cata
son baluchon servat le chou un match
haut en forme de baluchons d'un panneau
chez une pendule pour trois maillots et
de tissus à ma mère dans le baluchon
bruno damet la mort d'un poids lourd
bruno maman non mais c'est vrai tu me
fais quoi là
jeff suppan acloque elle est d'accord
c'est le grand carnaval ici
[Musique]